[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ah
horror movies don't work with a Walther
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you and your uh your honey your honey
what would we call them honey Aficionado
I don't know he always comes in he's
like I got this new honey that you have
to try and you get so he gets all wound
up about it because Sugar Rush
this Nicaraguan local what is it it's
local local area it's a local uh not
Ecuador okay that's enough of that but
it is tasty thank you yeah he's my
dealer uh hey before I move on to
anything else we're gonna be talking
about uh former Vice President Joe Biden
sitting down with the transgender tick
tocker and I don't know when it's no
longer a fringe as far as puberty
blockers for kids but I want you really
quickly name me something in recent
memory more ballsy than the UFC fighter
uh baniel Darius who by the way should
get a title shot he's on a seven fight
win streak promoting Christian I mean
almost actively trying to convert the
entire audience
in Abu Dhabi
comment that below that just happened
this week and I'm sitting there going oh
wow this is he's like wait he's in Abu
Dhabi they're gonna kill him
that's how did they ship ODI off too yes
well you know what though that's how you
that's how you measure a man's backbone
when he has something to lose that's one
thing to maybe do it in Kansas to do it
in Abu Dhabi well I hope that guy was
armor helicoptered out uh so we'll be
talking about uh that we'll also be
talking pointed former Vice President
Joe Biden have a really really bad
weekend also remember sashim Little
Feather we did the whole segment on her
yeah yeah uh where she came out and she
was accepting the award for Marlon
Brando never forgot his father yeah all
of that is complete horse crap she
wasn't even one part native American
really yeah her sisters came out said
none of what she said was true now that
she's dead they're uh I think there was
it called their dishing well also the
tear Native American guy yeah Italian
really true are you sure that's here I'm
serious yeah which is funny because you
think we would have you ever been on a
Native American reservation and you go
like there's a convenience store in
northern Michigan and you can clear yes
you can clearly tell you're like oh they
look there's a very strong look and
they're yeah honestly a statue-esque
people very much uh her I'm like that's
a white broad yeah part Mexican so
there's a certain power that they they
have that it looks like they have well
we suspected in the segment we said I
don't believe her turns out we were
correct it was just a hunch but now it's
the truth uh Gerald a how are you sir
I'm doing well how are you great had a
fun weekend good weekend yeah watch the
the fights and then uh it inspired a
segment here today because uh he's he's
still alive the Neil Darius good for him
well yeah so far as we know yes
yeah we haven't heard much thoughts and
prayers I haven't seen a ton on his
social media
and then uh you know I'm 11 quickest man
on his feet the fastest man to speak
quickest way in the west he and I are in
Nashville November 12th Ryman Auditorium
the rebels of the cause tour but there's
only two shows left with tickets one of
them is the 9 30 the second show in
Nashville out of credit.com Dave Landau
how are you sir Ahoy good how about you
I'm okay except for when we get to this
watch and react are we out of Baltimore
uh I don't know I don't know I don't
want to throw that in sorry we have no
idea I don't know maybe there are
tickets maybe there aren't by the way
scalpers who are buying them and selling
for like four or 500 to 300 that's not
us it is not us and I don't know how to
control it uh I've even put links up
when people have asked me on Instagram
where to find tickets you can go
Ticketmaster yes in those places legit
places yeah go to don't go to random
places no and it's really unfortunate
because they're making all this money
and they're ripping you off we don't
want to do that okay so uh it turns out
that uh Vladimir that uh
zielinski he's not the only one capable
of playing the piano with his member now
here's a twist
the person here and this went viral this
weekend playing with their phallus uh is
a beautiful and brave
woman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait for it
wait wait dong dong
laughs
I remember that in big yes
well there were two of them yes
is she playing chop dicks yes oh not yet
yeah no she's fine I think she's playing
cochner
uh I don't know hey but you know what
this beautiful and brave uh uh Marilyn
Manson uh album cover uh here uh look
this happened on television live TV
here's the real I don't use the word
offensive it's the lack of talent is
offensive it's mediocre it's just
sitting there like hey I'm naked there
should be a Dance I mean have you seen
puppetry of the penis they turn that
into the Eiffel Tower like they're
actually putting in some effort give it
the old College try but this is
something now on television we've talked
about this it's the low the soft expect
the bigotry of soft expectations and the
left does this with race the left does
this with uh with with gender with sex
with women obviously by lowering PT
standards the military and the police
force because they believe that women
you're not capable of meeting the same
standards by the way they are correct
and now we see it where if this was
something that is straight white male
would do would be a sex crime just to
see how far we've slipped forget the
term here do you remember the Janet
Jackson controversy the nipple slip
let's compare it let's compare that with
what we just saw here
[Music]
[Applause]
and there was a pasty and I wanted to
see the nipples and yeah and nobody
minded well people did people did get
upset I should say nobody where I was at
right
but comparing that to what we just see
it's like oh my gosh we saw a nipple
pasty there this this is not age
appropriate to mainstream Television
over there in in Europe a fallen a
fallen continent at this point uh a
transgender individual with breast
implants playing the piano with her
penis yeah tickling the ivories with her
soft penis yes well we couldn't play The
Black Keys we don't want racism no no
you can't reach them I mean it really
really the size of that thing it's like
well good good news you're already
mostly a girl yes you're partially there
yeah oh my gosh no you're right I mean
it'll be a sex crime that person would
have been hauled off and cuffs had it
been a straight white male and should
have still male honestly I don't know
either way we're pretty close sir white
straight does that is that a woman still
attracted to is it a lesbian or is it is
she a lesbian sorry I don't know how to
navigate this the point is it's it's
pure degeneracy and we allow it just
because someone decides to slap on a
dress also look put in a little bit of
effort don't blame us for being barely
passable it was like well it's because
Society look it's that's a that looks it
looks like I'm not saying it is looks
like a man in clown makeup
well and why are you clapping in the
audience like yeah everybody's like I
don't know I don't know anymore how to
react to things I sooner bought the
laugh track and The Flintstones yes
I believe it was a film from a live
studio audience I thought it was
every time it just hurt me a little it's
just all of this is is fraudulent and it
really is right now we are in a society
where we're racing to victim status and
by the way hit the like button you know
share if you're watching on YouTube it
helps with the algorithm uh it's a live
show Monday through Thursday at 10
Eastern right you can go watch it on
Rumble you can go on mug club or we'll
be playing they don't make them like
they used to we're not allowed to do
this on YouTube and today we are hitting
some some third rails
so third rails all the third rails with
her penis now yes sashim Little Feather
penis uh we did a segment on this not
too long ago right because it was the
anniversary and this was trending
because everyone was furious with John
Wayne because he gave an interview in a
magazine that doesn't exist anymore
um so it was a Sheen Little Feather
remember accepted the Academy Award for
Marlon Brando and there's some updates
here but for those of you who don't
remember Let me refresh your memory of
clearly Native American
sasheen Little Feather the Oscar speech
in 1973. that's hello my name is sasheen
Little Feather it's not catchy you're
not president of the national Native
American affirmative image committee
you're not I'm representing Marlon
Brando this evening and he has asked me
to tell you in a very long speech which
I cannot share with you presently
because of time but I will be glad to
share with the Press afterwards that he
very regretfully cannot accept this very
generous award he wrote on a Burger King
napkin and the reasons for this being
the treatment of American Indians today
by the film industry
excuse me
[Music]
look at the fake victim taste television
in movie reruns
and also with recent happenings at
Wounded Knee okay so why didn't you
remember when people took over a town
yeah well the story that we come yeah
yes where they were executing they took
over it there was a guy who would uh it
was a cop killer yeah anyway we did a
whole segment on that she was actually
talking about Marlins Wounded Knee when
he was running into Big Boy yes
they still offer quality food and
affordable prices fantastic so here's
what she had to say about her speech
also by the way and you may think it
seems self-aggrandizing
yes I spoke my heart not for me myself
as an Indian woman but for we and us for
all Indian people I had to speak the
truth whether or not it was accepted it
had to be spoken on behalf of native
people well according to her biological
sisters Rosalind Cruz and Trudy Orlando
none of that is true
she's not even native at all she's not
Native American at all so Orlando said
it's a lie and she also by the way let
me also preface this we don't have that
I don't have this in front of me she
also claimed that her father was an
Apache alcoholic this is what sort of
spurred them to speak out gotcha was she
was really throwing her family her
parents under the bus uh also by the way
that's incredibly racist because she
just picked a stereotype to make up a
story like yes yes my father's an Apache
alcoholic he can't handle his fire water
yeah which is redundant yes
so Orlando said it's a lie my father was
who he was his family came from Mexico
my dad was born in Oxnard
and uh assistant I mean you're not going
to be a Mexican-American princess you're
going to be an American Indian princess
it was more prestigious to be an
American Indian than it was to be
Hispanic in her mind and Cruz the other
sister said it is a fraud it's
disgusting to the heritage of the tribal
people and it's just insulting to my
parents Not only was her father not an
alcoholic or abusive her father didn't
drink he didn't smoke and he didn't
suffer from mental illness the truth is
that her grandfather abused her father
so she stole that story wow sprinkled a
little bit of racism in there to claim
he was an Apache alcoholic then claimed
it as her own and no one vetted it so
this is a couple of things here we're
going to get into this is just another
example in a long line of fake
victimhood because there's actually a
net benefit to claiming to be a victim
at this point man to be marginalized in
2022 boy is it a leg up not only that
but you used to say Well when the news
used to be in certain sort of
romanticization you know Nostalgia here
it never was they never vetted anybody
this woman when her whole life it took
her sisters after she died to come out
and say none of that was true her dad
was a Native American her dad was an
alcoholic she has zero Parts Native
American oh and by the way she said when
we were young we didn't we didn't have a
running water they said we did have
running water and we did have a toilet
every single thing that she said was
untrue and it would have been very
easily verifiable no one wanted to do it
yeah and I don't really give her sisters
a whole lot of credit for 40 something
years later coming out and being like Oh
yeah it was a lie yeah couldn't you have
like helped us all back then right
that's why I can see it like yeah I
guess I can see hiding it out of
embarrassment because they just don't
want anything to do with it right but
yeah they wanted to clear their parents
name is what they said they said because
their parents would run through the mud
as abusive Native American and it just
wasn't true it would have been better
while they were alive you would think so
yeah but now they'll never know right
that's yeah true they'll always well I
don't know if he's native he believes in
reincarnation oh that's right he's not
that
oh good I feel like Marlon probably did
that on purpose he hated Hollywood he
was like she's not Native American he's
like yes it's acting Elizabeth Warren's
not ready yet
and it's like wait till you see the
future that brings us to this point
right we've talked about the
marginalization the oppression Olympics
there's this presumption that of course
it's a huge leg up to be a straight
white male okay before I go on to the
list of fake victims here let me ask you
this and I'd like for you to comment
below genuine question just a gut
feeling let's say you go in for a job
interview and you're a straight white
male and you have the exact same
qualifications as black female as trans
individual lesbian or even just a woman
heart of hearts right now who do you
think's getting the job assuming all
other qualifications are the same
you really think they're going to pick
the straight white male just because
he's a straight or they're going to try
and fill a quota
one question I
or they're gonna pass me over because I
don't check any boxes I'm sorry the
trans card is just such a trump card now
you could just just wait to the very end
ah Sarah we just don't think you're
qualified but
but I'm trying for crying out loud Dave
took a leak on a tree and he's on a
watch list I know yeah yes it was in
front of a playground and yes the school
was in session yes it was the eighth
time yes and it was same school same
tree you shouldn't return to the scene
of the crime no but lesson learned
this person does it on a national
broadcast ah you know okay I guess
that's fine so it's totally it's totally
completely unacceptable and what do you
think would happen if just a straight
white male who was running well you know
what it would be Joe Biden who lied
about everything I believe it was in
1988 they found out he plagiarized they
found out he didn't finish in the top of
his class like he claimed they found out
he didn't get they found out he didn't
get three degrees like he claimed and
guess what that sunk his candidacy back
then he was a compulsive liar and so he
lost this woman is a compulsive she was
a compulsive liar and it took her
passing her parents uh passing and
finally her sisters to come out 40 years
later for us to figure it out let's go
through some other uh fake victims here
remember Sean King
yes yes thankfully enough he's kind of
gone away he's got Rachel dolezal you
have Kamala Harris who's faked a lot of
it when she's talked about you know
black white sorry Indie Native American
sorry Indian sorry maybe Native American
you have Elizabeth Warren who claimed
that she was part native American that
was complete and total horse crap you
have Ariana Grande who is Italian like
the Native American tear guy right she's
tried to play up the ethnic card here's
actually a side by side uh of her a few
years apart what
yeah wow she's white you have people who
fake and then so we have that there are
a lot of examples of people who are
completely Hispanic it's Italian oh
that's right okay
she's American Italian
s do this a lot yeah they do it as a
half Italian I gotta say I've never uh
pretended to be a Native American well
because Italian really isn't a whole lot
at this point it doesn't check any boxes
you're basically a white guy yeah oh
yeah of course you are and then racist
and you yells stuff outside of bars yeah
minorities I mean once in Brooklyn and
the Irish Bensonhurst yeah not fans and
both of them though they share a common
bond in their dislike of Jews yeah no
um back in the day so here's the thing
you have people who've completely
outright faked their identity okay again
that would that would mean there's an
incentive to do so but then you also
have people who are either biracial or
who do have a component of their
ancestry unlike Elizabeth Warren who has
none
and then of course they always try and
identify with the marginalized portion
of their identity of the ancestry and
again my only question is if it was such
an advantage if it was such a walk in
the park if life is easier when you're a
straight white male or female why is it
that people continually identify with
what would be perceived as the
marginalized group if they're biracial
and I know what you're going to say
that's because Society has already
decided if you're for example biracial
half white half black but we're not just
using those examples you just saw Ariana
Grande Vin Diesel whose mother is
completely European right has an
adoptive black dad he calls himself
quote definitely a person of color
also that's helpful the things I'm going
to do for my country yeah like lie about
my 23 and me yeah you know what I'm
gonna go with Vin Diesel that's a good
name yes
first name Vin like the car like a
carving yeah yeah it's diesel I like
diesel like these trucks and they got
Vince yeah diesel is like the gasoline
vintage like the car yeah because you
get more torque with diesel yeah I'm
very creative yes
for proof see Fast and the Furious 84.
okay it's really as great as the other
one
the Asians love it then you have Colin
Kaepernick right on the other hand he
was raised by white parents only claims
his black Heritage now I know that we
are going to say well that's because
people would identify look get rid of
the get rid of the teased fro okay and
people like I don't know Persian your
guess is as good as mine it kind of fit
in a number of different categories
these Abercrombie ethnic there you go
yes he's ethnic enough but you know they
would put him on a billboard because it
doesn't intimidate white people yeah
he's he's just enough he's just he also
identified as a good quarterback for a
little while that didn't work out either
right and then you have Barack Obama he
never called himself the first
half-white president even though he you
know was largely raised by a white
grandmother I mean look he's the least
black black guy who's been in that
office let's be honest Sarah Palin would
have dusted him on the basketball court
for crying out loud well I'm pretty sure
Clinton was the blackest at the time he
played the saxophone on Arsenio Hall
yeah yeah he's definitely came off a
little more but this is this is a
genuine question something that cannot
be observed statistically so we'll make
all the references available at
latticecredit.com for the examples again
it's a question to is anyone still
buying this that it is such an advantage
to be a straight white male at this
point how many people are rushing to
fake to be a straight white male how
many people out there are biracial how
many people out there uh who could and I
guess more conveniently pick a portion
of their ancestry saying yeah I'm just
irish-american you never see it and I
know before you say oh but Society has
forced us to conform to no no that's not
true especially when you look at the
entertainment industry and you look at
the representation in the media in the
entertainment industry and we're not
just talking racially we're talking
lgbtq right all of this there's a higher
percentage of representation of all
minority groups in all of our media and
I don't have a problem with that if it's
a meritocracy but at this point why are
people constantly rushing to lie to you
if it is in fact so much more difficult
to be a Native American so much more
difficult to be a black man Vin Diesel
so much more difficult to be and what is
Ariana claiming to be Italian
no that's what she is but she is Italian
but she goes she's really playing it up
I guess I thought she was pretending to
be Hispanic is she I thought Grande was
she the one who also pretended to change
the genders saying I'm I'm uh gender
neutral and then went back was that
Ariana Grande or is that the other one
who looks like Ariana Grande but isn't
Ariana Grande you know who I'm talking
about there's Ariana Grande and there's
the other one who's not who am I talking
about you guys know what I'm talking
about we need Gary to oh someone knows
Demi Lovato Demi Lovato that's it
they're the same person pretty much
have you ever seen them in the same room
together nope just saying
one's uh well Ariana's I think a little
uh more appealing who's the one who
licked the donuts and said I hate
America that was Grande no that was
Grande why did you know that so quickly
yeah we talked about on the show she
licked donuts oh that's right chest as a
servant said I haven't hate America I
don't know you see Ariana Grande lick
Donuts you never forget it yes oh geez
that's the kind of event that sticks
with you so
bones right I'm standing up for Native
Americans you're not Native American I'm
standing up for people of color you're
not a person of color Vin Diesel uh
let's compare that to someone with
actual brass pendulous balls you may not
know this guy just go with me here for a
second there's a fight on the UFC named
by Neil darush now I know you'll see him
and you'll think
hijacker But the irony here is
he's actually iranian-american he's a
Christian which again that and of itself
in and of itself the Fleer on that
someone who has a family they had
something to risk they had something to
lose so he's a Christian uh
iranian-american okay and I watched this
the fights this weekend which were
fantastic and we often have some friends
who are fighting if you've watched the
show we've had them on the show
um he gave a speech and there's always
you know a component of obviously a risk
if you go out and you make a very uh I
should say on the nose Christian except
in speech it's not very accepted in the
entertainment industry they're
significantly more forgiving in the UFC
but then it dawned on me that he gave
this speech in Abu Dhabi for context
watch this for the
Winner's decision
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I'm here with
vanilla Darius vanille once again man
you only step up the fight it does not
matter who how good does it feel to get
a victory over young up and coming
fighter like Mateo's gamrod
uh
I'm sorry Daniel but I got to take a
minute I need to dedicate this fight
my people in Iran I know you're
struggling I know you're fighting for
freedom I know it's a tough struggle I
want you guys to know we're praying for
you and we love you let me tell you one
more thing this might be the most
important thing you'll ever hear there
is true Freedom a freedom that no one
can take from you in the name of Jesus
Christ the son of God don't ever forget
that if you remember one thing I say
remember that honestly that's pretty
articulate considering his brain was
just scrambled and bounced off the mat
like a basketball but it's pronounced
Iran yes Iran Ariana Grande is
Italian-American Italian so keep in mind
Iran is 99 Muslim good for him though
UAE is 76 Muslim that's the crowd there
and I don't know if you know this uh
because I know we've talked about how
awful uh you know the Christian history
as a Western Christian history
um Muslims and they have this thing
called Sharia law and in a lot of these
countries if uh you convert or if you're
trying to convert from Islam then they
murder you mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah and if
you try to convert anybody else and I'm
not sure they double murdered but Abu
Dhabi is like throw you off a building
if you're gay Muslim but it's very close
Iran for sure is yeah well they still
have indentured servants and Abu Dhabi
people don't realize that that's slavery
yes
excuse me it's low-paid slavery yes it's
low paid slavery it's the people who
work the donut counter that Ariana licks
yes well they pay extra no a lot of
people don't realize this about UAE a
lot of people don't realize that the
laws that still apply often to women in
UAE I had a friend who competed at Abu
Dhabi in uh it's this prestigious
grappling tournament and she had to walk
around the building I don't know if this
is still the case today this would have
been maybe six seven years ago she had
to walk behind all of the men because
you weren't allowed to walk in front of
them at that point it's it's it's not
exactly what you think you go and you go
oh look they have a fake ski mountain oh
isn't that no no hold on a second there
really is an underbelly there that is
still uh not only unfair to women but is
incredibly incredibly fascist in a lot
of ways and this exists and every single
majority Islamic country and it has
since
the beginning of Islam just to be clear
it's not the same thing because there is
a system of laws by the way that require
punishment for those who don't know this
is when Ben Carson got in a lot of
trouble he said I believe that Sharia
law is incompatible or the Quran is
incompatible with the Constitution
because unlike the Bible there's a
system of laws that are prescribed which
is it not just hey convert or you'll go
to hell in the afterlife it's convert or
you die if you are Islamic and you
convert if you're Muslim and you convert
to Christianity you die if you try and
convert anywhere else you die if you
don't convert to Islam if you were
someone who happens to have already been
a Christian for example in the native
land you are subject to dimitude which
means you have a curfew which means you
have to pay a poll tax it's a second
class citizenship there's a system of
laws that exist in the Islamic world and
by the way with banil Darius a name like
that and a face like that tell me that
you didn't expect that voice
did not at all and by the way if that's
the only thing that he had ever said
about the subject he's never going back
to Iran that's enough for Iran to put
out a fatwa against him basically you
know the thing that Pakistan did against
you I think it's still active by the way
we'll have to see if we thanks for
bringing that up and drawing attention
to it to renew it or not uh 10-year
renewals on those things no but I mean
it literally is a regular travel agency
it's debt for him and death potentially
for his family at the very least they
would be social outcasts in the
community so I mean it was a huge people
were like oh whatever he said no no no
no that's life-changing yes life
changing for him and his family
potentially and not to mention as far as
popularity right there is some influence
in the UFC when you look at Abu Dhabi
right they have this deal with fight
Island and this guy's on I believe a
seven fight winning streak it's either
seven or eight he was a hot and cold
fighter and right now he just broke into
the top five he's unbelievable if you
haven't watched him and it is criminal
that he's not getting a title shot I
don't mean actually criminal I mean
figuratively so comment below if you
were familiar with it and if you uh you
know you some support I'm sure we can
find his social media handles by the way
just kind of as a briefing here you know
in Iran right now people they're
currently engaging these massive
protests against this you know
dictatorship of the Ayatollah and I
believe the Ayatollah is still on
Twitter Facebook can we get you guys to
confirm that they removed Donald Trump
while he was President
um protest started by the way after a 22
year old her name was a Masa amini uh
died while she was in the custody of
Iran's morality police that's an actual
thing and she was reportedly arrested
for breaking hijab rules they claimed
something else it hasn't been entirely
consistent but it shouldn't matter no
one should be arrested by the morality
of police ever we usually use it as a
figurative thing here like oh who are
you the morality police yes
exactly what morals do you have to
enforce oh they're not very moral no no
only their morality we can do whatever
we want and get away with it but if a
woman goes without a head covering Ah
that's a Line in the Sand buddy well
here's something we have a clip uh
coming up here really oh still on
Twitter lovely just not wanting to see a
woman's body is weird to me sorry I'm
gonna say well it's it's immodest they
say I can't be trusted I see a little
bit of ankle it's off to the racist no
what happens if I see the nape of her
neck oh boy I'm going to be playing The
Black Keys I can reach now it gets my
nine-year-old driver boy so I can rape
him yes exactly no homosexuality no no
it's just a power move right right yes
it's a power move I give never take it's
okay I find that offensive look into it
yes look into it remember they claim
remember when Ahmadinejad and the guy
who looks like Jake Gyllenhaal with a
terrorist beard he claimed that they
didn't have any homosexuals in Iran yeah
none yeah because you all do it in
secret or you kill them yeah yeah yes
it's a self-solving problem yes
so all the people of Iran when people
today say hey if I would have gone back
in time and I look at what happened with
slavery you know I would have done
something there's more slavery right now
on Earth than ever throughout human
history 40 something million slaves
we've talked about that but when people
say oh you know what I would have done
something to protect the Mars right now
you want to act like that person on
Channel 4 playing the piano with her
penis is marginalized but there are
people right now dying today and I don't
mean freedom of speech just here like in
what what you mean the freedom to say
offensive things I mean freedom of
speech simply to wear clothes simply to
speak uh as a non-muslim that's the
Baseline where talk talking about
protesters in Iran have been burning
hijabs have been cutting their hair and
by the way these people again
the measure of a man or a woman is what
do they do when they stand to lose
something and these people stand to pay
with their lives
[Applause]
everybody
[Applause]
good for them yeah they're standing up
all over the place against this stuff
but there was there was an Iranian
climber who was called up to climb early
this was going around I think two weeks
ago something like that and she wasn't
ready and so she didn't have her head
covering on it so she had to climb in a
competition without it and was
immediately met at the airport when she
got home into her home country gift
basket ah no I think it was the same
morality people a greeting committing a
gift casket yes uh exactly I mean
beating women who don't have head
coverings at the very least that's what
happened to this woman who was in
custody and then complications arose
from that I don't know the whole story
but it's it's entirely likely that they
just you know went way way way too far
beating her and she was not able to take
it right died because of the injuries
yep you should I mean I understand
cultural differences I get it you want
to enforce a rule that this is your
culture fine I disagree with it that's
why I don't live there and I'm never
going to go there but beating people for
that reason wasn't she a child like she
was a teenager right yeah 22 23 years
yeah very young okay and she was young
but here's the thing Iran has always had
this kind of running through this desire
for Freedom it has always been there
especially amongst the young people that
want to protest all the United States
needs to do is to stand up and say we
support you that's it yeah and right now
I mean I know politicians have said we
stand with people who are in in Iran no
no no no
Ayatollah Khomeini you're off Twitter
you think you should be able to wipe out
the entire country of Israel and Jews
should be pushed into the sea your words
not mine and you guys have no right to
tell women that they can't do that no
right whatsoever the United States
stands behind you right there there you
go Mass protests erupt in Iran problem
solved isn't it kind of interesting that
we you know we talked about Ukraine and
Russia where it's just one corrupt crap
hole versus another corrupt crap hole
and obviously my heart goes out to the
people the innocent people who are
affected by this but then we're dealing
with people who are actually you know
creating an uprising against what is
unilaterally agreed upon us a corrupt
government a government that is you know
I mean government the loses sense of the
word you're talking about a place where
human rights don't exist and we're not
sending dozens or now maybe hundreds of
billions of dollars depending on how you
do the Creative Accounting to help any
of these people we're not really doing
anything yeah and every time Israel
launches airstrikes to make sure that
they can't develop nuclear weapons to
set them back in their development for
that we kind of stand on the sidelines
and maybe wag our finger a little bit or
stay silent it's like no no no be like
yeah hell yeah we sent them in there we
told them like look we've got the
intelligence go every single time why
are we playing around with these guys
well that's also again why this guy you
know benildarius have all the respect in
the world from form and this is actually
the biggest controversy since I don't
know if you guys remember this but
there's a guy named Joel Romero
terrifying built like a he's one of
those guys he won a medal in the
Olympics he's from Cuba no one actually
knows how old he is yeah
and he doesn't really speak English and
he he tested positive but to be fair it
was a tainted supplement but he looks
like an action figure and this was after
uh Ireland had the gay marriage ruling
or whatever happened there but I don't
know if it was a referendum exactly and
he went up into this heavy accident he
caught all this Flack because he said he
said what happened to your USA no for
the gay hey Noah foreign
gay Jesus not not gay Jesus he was
trying to say don't forget Jesus uh I
think oh wait do we we have we have a
clip but tell me we have a clip okay
let's roll this clip hey
hey USC hi Miami hi Florida
listen people listen listen
[Applause]
what happened to you USA what happened
to you
what's going on you forget for the
depression the best of the world the
name is Jesus Christ what happened to
you wake up you were saying go go back
for you go go for Jesus not forget Jesus
people that's it
don't forget Jesus you should keep your
politics at home he's like no I'm not
saying for a guy I say no forget Jesus
okay you're saying that not for gay
Jesus no USA I say no for gay no forget
Jesus yes that's what we're hearing no
fruit no a UFC he's doing colleges now
who's gay Jesus hey hey
are those the only two you know hey hey
how do you understand
terrible every night you know he's
praying like I didn't mean to say you're
okay Jesus
[Laughter]
and then the most terrifying thing he
was fight that guy's built right oh yeah
and he was about to fight Michael
Bisping he was terrifying he was on a
tear and Michael Bisping in the balcony
and he's motioning like yeah giving him
the finger let's fight and it's even
scarier because he just turns him he
goes hey Michael Bisping I love you
you're like oh my God why'd you say that
we're about to witness a sex crime
I know you're mine you seem to have two
very different stances this is much more
intimidating I have split personality
USA
I don't want to gay Jesus but I like gay
me and you yes
I no forget Jesus but put in the class
when I'm with with Mike I love you
Fifty Shades and no forget Jesus
black forfeits the match
Mike would like to uh go uh ghee yes
again my question to you is what have
you done this is n't of a conversation
what have you done when you've had
something to risk you can comment that
below when have you we get these chats
all the time on mug like oh man I might
get in trouble in my job I think it's
it's time for everyone to start taking
some risks because that guy out there is
facing life or death consequences and
the fact that you might get called to HR
you know because you have a study Bible
in your desk really doesn't mean all
that much to the guy upstairs so uh
we're gonna move on here too
boy landlord this show really feels like
the Titanic because it's a sinking
tragedy no because all the women and
children have clearly long since left
I haven't seen such a sausage fest since
the Folsom Street Fair only they had
better physiques
and jokes have you heard the one about
the wholesome Street Fair [ __ ] who
confused the birth control for the prep
pill no what happened well the good news
he didn't get pregnant
test pill that helped you Gerald yeah
okay all right all right that's okay I
don't know why we give him the balcony
I thought we took that down but I did I
did realize it's still there no it's
still there by then I think you know
exactly what he's insinuating I think
you know what he meant no photo
I'm not
you imagine if that guy saw the Folsom
Street Fair I was just like hey
just gay Jesus eight guys turn around
no if I want to have sex on flow yeah
okay
so USA he says we can have sex and poop
in the streets no I say hey no oh
he says let's go he's just the most
misunderstood man in America
I haven't seen its bone chillingly scary
all right hey uh we just had so many
segments we wanted to hit from this
weekend former Vice President Joe Biden
he's kind of giving us more father
father
oh boy he's giving us more [ __ ] he's
not he's not until it comes to shower
time yes uh oh former Vice President
Biden is now on the campaign he's on the
campaign Trail uh and he's trying to
help candidates I'm like that's okay
stay home and so he's on the road quite
a bit and of course the more you see
former Vice President Joe Biden just the
worse it is for him so that brings us to
this week invite wait if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or Trump then you ain't black I have
not made that formal decision but it's
my intention my intention to run again
and we have time to make that decision
uh Dr Biden is for it
Mr President oh Dr Biden thinks that uh
my wife thinks that uh
that I
that were that were doing something very
important I think the best way to make
the judgment is to uh to you know watch
me you know am I slowing up am I don't
have the same Pace in it or you know uh
and that old joke you know uh
um everybody talks about the you know
the new 70s 50s and all that stuff you
know I you know it could be I'm a great
respecter of faith I could get a disease
tomorrow I could you know drop dead
tomorrow and will people who have
privately held loans will they at some
point become eligible for this
forgiveness because they no longer are
we are working on Pathways there to
support those but we're moving as
quickly as possible to provide relief as
many people as possible
at all
yes
read it man you're a good educated how
would you say your mental focus is
oh it's focused
I said I think it's I I haven't look
I have trouble even mentioning even
saying to myself my own head the number
of years I know more think of myself as
being as old as I am than fly
I mean it's just not uh
I haven't observed anything in terms of
there's not things I don't do now that I
did before whether it's physical or
mental or anything else wait if you have
a problem figuring out whether you're
for me or Trump and you ain't black
we're all gonna die yes yeah I think
he's on what adrenochrome and Xanax yes
as in cocaine for uppers yeah yeah like
I just don't understand he's like you
know you're saying the 50s the new 70.
that's great thank you I was worried for
a second yeah
terrified it's also not relevant because
you're 90. yeah it's also not an old
saying yeah but it's not even a new
saying yeah one could argue it's not a
saying please tell me you're not the one
negotiating to keep a nuclear bomb from
going off in uh Ukraine right now please
tell me just as body language honestly
my heart does go out to the former vice
president by someone who has had people
in the family who've suffered memory
loss and I'm not a doctor I'm not
diagnosing them but I do see the same
kind of signs that I've seen with
Alzheimer's in my family yeah uh could
be dementia I mean I had a relative who
would just ran people with shopping
carts this guy was a professor this guy
is just fun yeah but then when he was
always with it it was a totally
different person and he laughed his ass
off he was back to his childlike State
and
where's his family though who I'm angry
with his family people who are supposed
to be looking out for him he'd be better
off growing his nails and pissing in
jars in his home theater oh yeah yeah
he's he's like the old guy at like your
old relative at a family reunion where
two minutes into the conversation you're
like great to see you Uncle Joe yeah I'm
gonna go because this is making me
uncomfortable right you'd be slightly
uncomfortable except you're angry for
the fact that he's so handsy yes well I
love I love it could you just let go of
my daughter so I can go food
that's a doll Joe stop sniffing the doll
okay he's trying to bring it back to
life like Annabelle yeah no I love in
that interview where he's like well just
you know I understand he was saying that
criticisms of somebody that maybe is
getting older and starting to lose a
step they're fine it's fine to criticize
that because but just look at me look at
what am I am I uh have I lost a step yes
and then we played like all these clips
and it's like yes you should never have
said just look at what I'm doing because
what you're doing tells us
you might be 25th amendment but I've had
people say you know like well I just
feel bad for them you know like I really
I just think that we shouldn't be like
shaming him for that for getting older
and it's like he's the president yes I'm
not sure that's the problem you should
be able to talk about if he was anyone
else fine we shouldn't have to put
Cheerios in the bowl for when the
president pisses no it's uh
perfect aim I gotta hit those little
lows just for breakfast you can't do
that the doctor gave me Cheerios squash
banana Kamala can't do that I know for
sure oh
SpaghettiOs what what did you say
Applejacks they don't taste like apples
oh boy what we like and cut wow okay
yeah he's the leader he's a former vice
president yeah leader of the Free World
if you can't shame someone for being
wholly incapable of doing their job and
I mean by the way when did criticism
become equated with shame this is the
brilliant Ploy right shame is bad no one
should feel shame some people should
feel ashamed yes plenty of people should
feel shame and then criticism is not the
same as shaming somebody we're not
shaming former Vice President Joe Biden
because he is maybe suffering from
memory loss or clearly he's lost a step
we are saying he is Holy and capable of
doing the job that he was fairly and
freely elected to uh and uh you can be
compassionate but also be furious with
the current state of affairs his
handlers the party the platform that has
thrust him there and his uh family who
are just Hangers On who are not looking
out who's looking out for Dad for
husband for a grant for Grant none of
them are going to come out and tell the
truth that's how that's an evil evil
family could you sit back and watch if
your dad was going through that never
could you sit back and watch and say
yeah give him a power saw I would no but
if I was if I was his family member and
he was running for president I would
come out and torpedo his campaign like
there's I'm sorry I would come out and
be like look he's he's lost a step it's
okay he was the vice president of the
United States it's a great achievement
you're in politics your entire life you
suckled at the government maybe not the
best achievement in the world but you
did it right off into the sunset as a
quote-unquote powerful vice president
who told the Ukrainian people they
weren't getting money unless they got
rid of a prosecutor going after your
son's business right right but still
yeah if you were in the family you would
I think you would come out I probably
yeah you wouldn't say all the horrible
stuff he did yeah but you just go look
it's a different part of the the brain
like my grandfather my dad said he had a
stroke yeah he could he couldn't speak
at all but he could sing happy birthday
right it's the same with former Vice
President Joe Biden he can still do
corrupt things yes
he can still collect money and know the
exact to the penny we're supposed to get
the underage shower massages yeah it's a
totally different but it's not the
frontal lobe yeah but then they have to
remind him not to eat an ice cream come
upside down yeah
the only guy who gets brain freeze
before he is
what is this he fell asleep during a
live interview guys and you know you
know they gave him that interview at
like 9 00 a.m or something right because
he's the leader of the Free World from 5
a.m to 1 pm but after that he's no good
to anyone 1pm is dinner time but that's
true bedtime
153. and here's how you know he's a
puppet because if you look at what
former Vice President Joe Biden said I
mean Not only was he racist but you look
at how he was actually kind of more
traditional as it related to the
lgbtqaip when he was trying to uh
portray himself as a practicing Catholic
that's completely out the window so this
brings us to this other story here
um where former Vice President Joe Biden
sat down this was going everywhere uh
viral everywhere for all the wrong
reasons uh a transgender Tick-Tock
activist say that three times fast and
then try not to throw up Dylan Mulvaney
not to be confused with uh Dermot
mulrooney or Dylan McDermott and I still
think they're the same person yeah they
are have you ever seen him in the same
room that's the truth I've always
thought the same thing I don't know one
was in Four Weddings and a funeral one
was in the practice in American Horror
Story which one has more talent and
range I don't think either exactly so
it's the same dude Tick Tock activist
Dylan Mulvaney I'm mad about it and the
former vice president sat down to
discuss the term now is gender affirming
care let me be really clear as to what
this means gender affirming care means
transitioning young children which we
were told was a fringe Theory and I'll
get to that in a second so former Vice
President Joe Biden with everything
going on right now in the world said oh
it's really important to sit down with a
tick tock influencer to push the idea of
transitioning children during an
exclusive interview here's a clip
foreign
Joe Biden with uh Dermot mulrooney and
it it feels like Republicans have turned
trans and non-binary people into this
thing to blame society's downfall on in
some ways and this narrative is not only
dangerous to our mental health but also
our physical safety and particularly
trans women of color are being murdered
at an alarming rate more than any other
group of people thank you how can
Democratic leaders be more effective in
advocating for us trans people and our
families and our lives and our
opportunities
I'm not being facetious when I say this
being seen with people like you
know I mean it I genuinely mean it and
no one's cutting you off people fear
what they don't know
he's a reading prompter and when people
realize individuals realize oh
this is what they're telling me to be
frightened up this is the problem this
is I mean people change their minds do
you think States should have a right to
ban gender affirming health care I don't
think any state or anybody should have
the right to do that
as a moral question as a legal question
I just think it's wrong well look first
off when they say oh Society blames
their downfall they're afraid of us
people fear what they don't know I will
tell you right there I'm a little bit
scared that the former vice president
sitting down with the bent neck lady I
do think that it's not necessarily the
best
raving psycho
and
and you know that story right where I
fell asleep to the Christmas yule log on
Netflix in a dark room in a dark room
and then it decided to auto play
Haunting of Hill House and that's what
you woke up my pulse has never been
higher until I saw that interview and
don't think it's lost on me your brains
they had to pre-tape it we're live right
now just so you know nothing up my
sleeve let's go to CNN really quickly
just just show them what it is right now
so you can see the clock we are live
right now we do this without a net so
that you can see this happening in real
time they had to make sure they
pre-taped that and cut it and cut it and
cut it and sanitize it yeah and even
then it still doesn't make sense no no I
mean it let me finish and she's saying I
don't know what who's not letting you
finish let me stop hey
she has a video that she put out before
too where she's like I'm wearing the
color of a trans flag and she's going
out and you're like you're doing a
stereotype of a girl yes exactly it's a
little like it's a kind of offensive I
think to women but used to remember they
made Barbie fat because like these are
offensive stereotypes yeah and then they
decide of course when you're talking
about take Caitlyn Jenner take this
individual as an example it's let's
perpetuate The Stereotype of what a
woman should be well now We're Off to
the Races and by the way just for a
little more backstory who is this person
the Germany Dylan McDonough I know
that's not the name but that's what's
called the popping in my head yeah uh
who was interviewed by the former vice
president
hot girl summer hot girl summer day 75
of being a girl and I've been carrying
around tampons and pads for the past two
months but I've actually went up so
let's do it
for a small medium and large based on
the size of your Barbie pouch but after
a Google I found out it's actually the
level of your flow I thought Barbie was
toxic my crotch doesn't look like other
women's crotches sometimes because mine
does all the time little Barbie pockets
okay we all just normalize women having
bulges sometimes because we're coming up
on bikini season baby and you might see
a bulge or two so normalize the Bulge we
are normalizing the Bulge women can't
have bulges and that's okay wow it's
like an incredibly Disturbed Jack Black
Betty girls yeah I know what you're
thinking anything girls shouldn't have a
boat no and a girl can have a bulge and
a girl can have a poach they'll have a
bowling balls
they let that in the White House yes
it's just it is absolutely normalize the
Bulge for women why don't you just let
somebody with the road flares tape to
him into the way yeah exactly I mean
look take away the the the trans
identity thing if a person had made
videos like that I'd be like yeah you're
on a watch list for not coming to the
White House or anywhere near where the
president is ever going to be yes yes
and they're like no no you do the
interview the only time it might be
appropriate to say normalize the bows is
if you're speaking to a bunch of women
who've grown up next to a radiation
plant well in the tampon video she
actually takes the tampon and puts it in
water which I actually did as a kid and
it filled the whole glass because I
found one my friend and I we were in
Canada and it was out of a vending
machine we were like why would it fill
the whole glass but
I don't know she does it and she pulls
it out and she's like oh it's for a
smaller flow it looks like a beautiful
butterfly I'm like what this person's
not well Barbie pouch where you go gonna
you've been carrying around tampons how
many stories have we covered where they
want to get rid of Barbie the left
because I think it's toxic it's a
negative female stereotype it's this
transgender individual Dylan whatever
name his she's I'm not trying to use the
right or wrong pronouns okay I want I
see the picture in front of me and my
brain can't compute it so it messes me
up just to be clear before you accuse me
of a hate crime that looks like a man it
looks to most people like a man in uh in
makeup and leather pants oh if Trump
said instead of I grab them by the you
know if he would have said I like to
grab him by the Barbie pouch he wouldn't
have been president no
that's how creepy that term is and look
frankly I'm open to oh I'm fine with I
like a good bulge in the ladies Barbie
who does it like a good bulge I've never
look come what cabal no Bells your big
bulge Hillary would have won in a
landslide well Hillary is probably one
who wants to normalize the Bulge
and Mike Obama
I think you can't say that what somebody
else says on the other side is wrong and
evil when it's like they say that and
it's like that's a weird thing to say
just Barbie pouch right and normalize
women's bulges and her penis I'm sorry
I'm still stuck on that it's summered
with boobs than a penis I'm just like I
don't know okay it's summer so some
women have bulges yet what ones that are
wrecked
excuse me it's a man okay well seriously
this is some this is a perfect example
of them hijacking women please comment
below and hit the like button if you're
I know a lot of you watching listening
right now are women this person has now
decided they speak for you lots of lots
of women have bulges no you have a bulge
lots of women can get erections yes no
you can get an erection let's be clear
lots of women I speak for women women
look women do have their own issues of
course women have issues that are unique
to them I understand that just like men
do and some can argue women have more uh
going into bikini system bikini uh
season
with a giant penis in your bikini is not
Chief amongst them for most women
it's almost like it's not designed for
that it's almost like yeah it's been
hijacked almost so and by the way what's
important about this is you have the
former Vice President of the United
States sitting down discussing gender
affirming care and this is necessary
because we've discussed this Virginia
law right states have to protect parents
because we've talked about this too with
same-sex marriage okay when we went back
I never supported same-sex gay marriage
not because I don't of course civil
union all the same property sharing
rights whatever the problem is when you
declare marriage a fundamental human
right you've now declared that men and
women are fundamentally interchangeable
that children do not need both a mother
and a father or that it's not ideal
because that's why marriage laws exist
in this country so when I went back and
I discussed this look there is an issue
here you're going to open up Pandora's
box with the same sex marriage as
opposed to having civil unions which by
the way many gay people run you look at
Elton John and Rush Limbaugh agreed on
that no one was trying to write goaltend
reject gay people putting each other in
the will
now we're here with they said hey what's
what what you're just saying that adults
can't make their own decisions no one's
talking about children no one's talking
about transgender children well look
once you declare Merit a fundamental
right you've had in Canada for example
pastors who've been jailed for saying
they won't be involved with it because
it violates their conscience it violates
their their principles of their religion
what do you think is going to happen if
you declare as former vice president
just said there that no one should have
a say if it's a fundamental human right
for a child to transition oh now a
parent not allowing their child on
puberty blockers is violating their
fundamental human rights it's tantamount
to abuse and Child Protective Services
can come and take your kids away which
by the way has already started happening
depending on the state
look behind you there's a slippery slope
but you've been gaslit we're members of
the media and members of the
entertainment industry have claimed time
and time again that the LGBT agenda that
this normalizing with kids at home
you're just crazy it's no no that's
that's just that's a fringe point of
view you don't need to worry about it
here you go here's proof so-called
because opponents of gay marriage got
nothing and they tried everything
starting with a good old classic
slippery children sometimes make a
slippery slope argument if we allow
same-sex couples to marry then why not
polygamy why not incest why not
bestiality but conservatives such as
Justice Antonin Scalia warned for
decades that the most basic rights for
Gay and Lesbian Americans would put us
on a slippery slope to legalize polygamy
along with and I quote adult incest
prostitution masturbation adultery
beastiality and obscenity those are the
bits that Elizabeth warned you about
because no one back then predicted
children on puberty blockers you should
legalize prostitution you should tax it
and test the girls to keep them safe
that's where I stand Dave for [ __ ]
2024.
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait no wait no wait let me let me no
I'm serious
this way Hunter can stop having him
trafficked directly to his house that's
a joke
just brings them in a giant cake every
time like under siege like you don't
have to do that every time or just a big
cartoonish Acme crate that he opens
people know what you're doing it's more
fun this way yeah there's eight alive
ones and two dead ones oh just trying to
keep it's it's the spice of life you
have to keep it a surprise so here's the
thing they said oh slippery slope now
you have Jon Stewart saying that it's
abuse to not allow children transition
you have John Oliver I'm willing to bet
that every single person in that video
supports transitioning children to some
degree and we know that every single
member of the platform the DNC right now
in this Administration does if if anyone
doesn't we haven't heard them speak out
it's not a fringe point of view
he thinks it's just wrong for parents to
protect their children from gender
affirming care as they call it and that
means doctors coming in that means
surgeons coming in that means social
workers coming in saying oh this isn't a
tomboy this girl is actually a boy and
you need to acknowledge their
fundamental human right to exist well
sure I acknowledge the right to exist
and that means thousands of dollars in
surgery and in hormonal care so here
yeah go ahead so what I'm going to say
is you know how they they actually
avoided saying the word children or kids
because if you're over age you can you
can go get this Care on your own right
there's I don't believe that there are
any restrictions maybe some states have
some kind of random miscellaneous rules
but they said gender affirming care not
wanting you to think oh they're talking
about a 12 year old they're talking
about somebody who has to have mom and
dad's permission they're trying to like
sneak this thing in under gender
affirming care in general no no no
they're talking about kids yeah and just
won't say it let me ask you this can a
12 year old and by the way we're talking
about kids as low as four five six yeah
showing you I was trying to be generous
yes but let's say can a 12 year old uh
consent to sex no
okay what does does cutting off your
penis or does sewing up your vagina does
it affect your sex life
for the remainder of your life yes we
know that absolutely does in some cases
they can't climb extra the rest of their
life uh okay can a 12 year old
would a 12 year old be allowed to get
silicone breast implants it was just a
girl who said other girls have bigger
boobs than I do would that be considered
good parenting no of course not what
about a young boy who wanted to get
plastic surgery because he didn't like
you know at nine years old didn't like
the way his face looked felt
self-conscious
would you allow a 12 year old boy would
you allow a 12 year old Italian boy to
get electrolysis on his trapezoids
probably not you'd probably say it's age
and appropriate when they say yeah no
but actually I'm a girl oh okay 250
000 in a hormonal replacement and of
course in surgical care which is
completely elective and unnecessary and
by the way we have the stats on this
we know that about 80 anywhere as low as
87 and there are older studies that are
as high as 95.
call it 87 that's the lowest that we
have of children they completely grow
out of they completely grow out of
thinking that they are trans if you just
do nothing the moment you give them
puberty blockers
zero percent grow out of it so we go
from 87 percent of kids growing out of
it to zero percent by the way that eight
that uh that remain that 100 in the case
of kids with puberty Pluckers they're
now in a statistical
pool a reality a 42 percent attempted
suicide rate
if there is if if any other scenario
whether it's living their true self
whether it's bulimia whether it's
anorexia whether it's someone with body
dysmorphia if they were on the road to
to something that we know beyond any
shadow of a doubt increases their risk
of suicidal ideation and actually
carrying out suicidal action to 42
percent
wouldn't you do everything as a parent
that you could to stop them but now the
government wants to stop you
that is the most perverse
uh encroachment of government that I can
think of between the relationship
getting themselves between a parent and
a child yeah it's also not true self of
course yeah
yeah no that we all have to when we live
our true self we all have to get to you
know half a million dollars in surgery
to look like what we were meant to look
like yeah because God doesn't make
mistakes but God made me looking like
this and my uh my my Plumbing operates
like this so I'm going to correct all of
God's mistakes well yeah and the thing
that makes you suicidal and hate
yourself that's definitely your true
self that's your truth when I go deeper
and try to you know find peace you want
to the thing that makes you die you want
to glorify it no no it's society that
makes them suicidal even though it's
higher than Jews and Auschwitz and
American slaves
something something Target bathroom and
it doesn't change after they transition
it doesn't change it doesn't get any
better no there's actually been a lot of
um
um people that have transitioned and
gone back that I've actually talked to
online a couple times and uh you know
for numbers and sex and um but no
honestly like they've reached out
because of our show and they've said you
know like I had this my and I had this
at 16 I was allowed to have this and now
at 17 you know like a year later and now
they're you know 25 30 years old and
they're they're Advocates against it but
it's because it was a year later they
changed their mind and they had a
mastectomy right you know stuff like
that and it's it's kind of sad because I
think that both those those voices need
to be heard right not and not shun like
they're saying something bad it's like
this person lived in and experienced it
they should be allowed to say like you
can draw your own opinion sure that's
the part I don't get so why silence the
voice of somebody who's experienced it
firsthand right well and I I'm kind of
I'm putting this together in my head I'm
thinking through okay what if my son has
issues when he's 10 12. God forbid if
don't you put that evil on your
Offspring you don't know if he's a son
yet well
thanks for hey you got a penis you're a
son oh boy I hit my doctor Square in the
bottom yeah right
but walking through that process yes
parents I understand that that's a very
difficult situation to be in but parents
have gotten to the point where they
never want to tell their kids no they
never want to actually parent their
children but it's part of the process
that you have to go through and you have
to make sure
if you are neutral on this at the very
least you should make sure they get to a
point where they can make good decisions
in life I don't know like buy a beer
vote Rent A Car those age ranges
something like that where you can
actually go okay this wasn't a fad but
here's the thing I'm really not
understanding right now
this day and age in school where it's
promoted to explore your sexuality to
explore your gender identity is this
really that big of a thing for kids
right now is this really the the hateful
environment that they're making it out
to be where they quote numbers like
trans female murder rate for people of
color is higher than any other people
group period I would like to do some
research into that and see how they got
that number is it really it's a niche
sampling size
school you go do whatever you want yeah
well that's the thing it's like hey I
would like to buy this beer I'm sorry
you're a can of age but there's a fake
[ __ ] attached to it right right this way
would you like I'm sorry Blue Ribbon it
sucks too and by the way this is a big
part of it too is you know feminist I
was just watching the show The Watcher
uh I think that's what yeah the Watcher
I think uh I think it was on Netflix
because we were going to review it so
they talk about their daughter and the
dad says hey you're not even 16 you
shouldn't be wearing lipstick or hey I
can see your bra strap you know be
careful the message you're sending out
to young men and uh the mom says you
know we were never going to be like this
we said we were going to raise young
girls who own their sexuality here's
something that I wanted to bring up come
on is when they say own their sexuality
this is from feminists right his own
their sexuality largely meant being as
promiscuous as men and obviously it's
backfired and obviously that is the
start of the blurring of gender lines
that men and women are the same but let
me ask you this women if you're watching
right now
how does this pass a sniff test yes I'm
owning my sexuality I'm owning my value
by giving it away let's just look at
supply and demand let's look at basic
economics the concept of scarcity is
there any other example that you can
think of where you increase the value of
something by making it more readily
available and a greater Supply
in other words how is it that women
believe they increased their value by
owning their sexuality which meant
giving it away well I'm in charge of it
well hold on a second unless you're
talking about rape you've always been in
charge with it and by the way we're all
against rape but the idea of free love
and free sex where else would that
increase the value of anything by giving
it away for free yes let more men have
one-night stands with you that'll
Empower you say anything think about
anything if if it doesn't make sense if
oil was given away for free Red Bulls
right if you ever see the red Red Bull
girls that come up they have their
backpack they go man I'm dragging oh
thank God the Red Bull's gonna give it
away for free now you're not gonna buy a
Red Bull
they were trying to seed the market and
get you to try before you buy well yeah
they also throw in some Fentanyl and
that's a problem yeah that is a problem
that's a labeling issue you said it was
cigarettes
in bars to get you hooked and Captain
Morgan would do that remember Captain
Morgan were coming to bars they would
give stuff away for free yeah they give
you shots and stuff but just a little
just a little bit but then they charge a
premium like and if you'd like more you
have to purchase it here but I always
did you've never increased the value of
anything by giving it away for free
we've said this right now is a wrong
message to young men and to young women
and it all started by deliberately
delivering the wrong message to young
women and now we said women can act like
men
and that's one of the greatest by the
way turns of reverse psychology that
I've ever seen men were like don't do
that don't have sex freely with everyone
you'll be
totally valuable
skunked again don't be just like us
here's some cab fare and we have all
we've gone through all this right by the
way increased estrogen levels in men
that increases the risk of cancer also
in women when we've talked about
hormonal replacement therapy in kids it
can increase brain swelling vision loss
right there are all kinds of problems
you can go check out the references at
live with credit.com but now it's being
echoed by England's national Health
Service uh and there's someone from
there who just released a statement the
English National Health Service they're
saying that most children who think they
are transgender are quote just going
through a phase so the NHS plans to ban
puberty blockers yeah no and the NHS
will now be banned for saying yes from
all social media because they know
better than the NHS outside of very very
specific clinical trials are going to
ban puberty blockers for minors they
also the NHS warned doctors to not
encourage children to change their names
or pronouns here's a quote social
transition such as changing a young
person's name and pronouns or the way
that they dress is not a quote neutral
act doing so could have signed
significant effects in terms of their
psychological functioning in a case by
the way you needed any more evidence of
the slippery slope Microsoft has gotten
in on that action with their new lgbtq
plus logo called the banner of pride
well I what you know they turned off the
comments on that so somebody throws some
soup on it that's Windows 90. take a
guess that's the I don't know how many
genders there are flags so we'll just go
with you know all the colors yeah
exactly let's just toss it all in there
how could that be any less relevant to
computer software it's a kaleidoscope
yes that's all it is it's what Harry was
looking through when he was robbing the
house
so this is the NHS what happened to
trust the science yeah this is why I
don't say just trust this scientist they
appeal to Authority fallacies incredibly
uh it's incredibly subversive because
people go oh yeah okay Dr fauci I don't
know you assume that you're an idiot so
you assume the people in power know but
what do you do when the people in power
the actual doctors are saying you really
shouldn't do this this is bad and again
this isn't science like Dr fauci when
you're talking about the NHS where
they're trying to make a prediction in
the absence of information they are now
issuing prescriptions in the face of a
preponderance of evidence now
all of the evidence that we have points
to the fact that it is not only bad for
children
but it is deadly for children who
decided to ignore all of the science
that we have available again it's not a
hypothesis it's already been it's
already been tested
the former Vice President of the United
States he's decided to take it upon
himself to fly in the face of Science
and say and I'm not kidding it's the
most emotional no State should have any
right to stop parents from telling you
you can't be on puberty blockers hey
oh that's a slippery slope way way off
in the distance like Wilson in Castaway
that's where you are
share if share the show if you can hit
the like button we have to go to mug
Club I realize we're kind of running
late a little bit today we're going to
play they don't make them like they used
to and uh by the way Walther sponsor
we're doing a series of commercials here
all this week going up to Halloween
spooky
I don't really need to there's I don't
really need a plug I'm just go to your
local gun range uh and try it just ask
just try it the balls will sponsored
this show no one I know who has tried
them uh hasn't preferred them to the
other uh handguns that they have that's
it that's that's it yeah they're cool
they're cool they're they're exclusive
and you can protect they're deadly on
Halloween they practically sell
themselves I got two golden ones of
dragons yes exactly thank you Caster
Troy okay YouTube piss off
foreign
[Music]